second question today hey David who do
you think was more destructive in their
first two years george w bush or donald
trump I wish I could say definitively it
was Bush or Trump but the answer is that
it depends george w bush in his first
two years made the disastrous decision
to go to or at least was well on his way
to his disastrous decision to go into
war with iraq no two years it actually
would have been if he was inaugurated
January 2001 January 2013 okay we were
two months from the invasion of Iraq
although the decision had by and large
been made by that time what am I talking
about in 2000 2001 I don't even know
what I have the dates completely wrong
in any case george w bush made
individual decisions on policy during
his first two years which i believe were
more damaging in total than the
decisions that donald trump has made
however Donald Trump has done way more
of a different type of damage during his
first two years which includes the
wrecking of some alliances really
important alliances with other countries
around the world and the sort of total
debasing of American politics in a way
that is going to take a very very long
time to recover from the tariffs are
probably the policy that Donald Trump
has done or enacted that are going to
have the longest term affect and are
going to take the longest to sort of
unwind and undo but I believe that on
policy George W Bush was far more
destructive during his first two years
in terms of the discourse and the impact
on US relations and u.s. standing around
the world george w donald trump was far
more damaging during his first two years
but there's way more time left for
Donald Trump to in total be way more
damaging of a president than george w
bush send me your thoughts if you
disagree with me